[inaudible]
have you ever asked yourself,
which is the best countries live in?
Well,
when we want to know which country that
is,
we usually tend to look at the country's
GDP,
but however important and relevant this
indicator might be,
it does have certain limitations.
See this statistic is too wide and it
can hide the influence of bubbles,
the actions of dishonest politicians and
is more complex issues like accounting
for the online economy.
It is true though that wealth and
comfort are closely related to the GDP,
but it is not an exact correlation.
Let me explain.
We could be analyzing a country that has
a higher GDP per capita than another,
but the last occurs have a better
welfare system despite having that lower
GDP and there are also other factors to
consider that not strictly economic but
also affects the social wellbeing of
people of such as security and freedom.
All right.
All right,
so probably know something you thinking
right now and that's that.
Well do these things or result from
having a higher GDP anyway?
Well,
yeah,
they kind of do,
but it usually takes awhile before any
of this can be seen in terms of numbers
and statistics.
For instance,
if you look at Kuwait GDP per capita,
it's definitely higher than Germany's.
If given the choice,
most people would probably rather live
in the latter.
It's also more likely that Germany is
going to be involved in complex and high
added value activities like creating
patents and innovative companies.
In other words,
[inaudible] it might become richer,
but at the same time Germany might be
taking better advantage of its wealth in
order to produce welfare,
sustainable wealth,
technology and knowledge and most people
would regard doing that as a pretty
sensible decision and this whole
complicated thing.
That's why they're on new indicators to
try to make a more accurate
approximation so that we can work out
the prosperity and comforts of different
nations.
One of them is the famous [inaudible]
gotten prosperity index.
National success is about far more than
just GDP.
It is about a healthy and happy life,
a good education for our children,
a clean and protected environment,
family and communities.
We can rely on a safe place to live up
to unity's,
to start a business or get ahead and the
freedom to be who we want to be.
This is true prosperity.
And you know what's,
at least according to these rankings,
the most prosperous nation on earth is,
well,
that would be New Zealand's most
prosperous country.
Yeah.
Trying to get a deeper knowledge of the
prosperity of the country beyond the
GDP.
The GOSSAN prosperity index considers
tons of different factors,
economics,
business,
civil liberties,
government education environments.
Honestly,
every aspects that accounts for quality
of life in a country.
So in the latest ranking,
the results,
it was pretty clear.
Nowadays,
New Zealand's the land of the Kiwi is
the most prosperous country on the
planet as honestly,
this wasn't really much of a surprise.
And He Zealand's has taken this position
six times in the last 10 years.
Not Bad.
Right.
And now you might be wondering,
which are the countries New Zealand is
competing with in order to win the crown
of the best country on earth.
Well,
you wouldn't be surprised to find at the
top of the list countries like Norway,
Finland,
Switzerland,
Canada or Australia,
it's pretty tough competition.
I should also mention at this point that
soon enough we're going to be explaining
on this channel how New Zealand achieved
so much of this after so much crisis.
If you want to catch that video,
be sure to subscribe to this channel,
but for now,
let's move on.
Now,
if you think New Zealand is just ranks
number one for this indicator,
well you couldn't be more wrong if we
consider the doing business ranking.
For instance,
this is a ranking by the way,
that classifies countries according to
how easy it is to set up a company and
do business.
We can see that New Zealand is also in
the number one spot in the latest
ranking New Zealand dethrone Singapore
as easiest place to do business.
If we use the index of economic freedom
from the Heritage Foundation,
we will see that New Zealand is in third
position right after a Singapore and
Hong Kong.
Then if we use the ranking of the Fraser
Institute,
a ranking that considers both economic
and civil freedoms.
New Zealand's is also in the top three
just behind Hong Kong and Switzerlands
and if this is not enough for you as you
want more specific information,
I can also tell you that New Zealand is
the least corrupt country on earth
according to Transparency International.
This is a position that it shares with
Denmark.
Yes.
Unlike other countries that we happen to
know very well,
it is very uncommon for this country's
government to have their hands in the
till.
Furthermore,
this is also one of the safest countries
in the wells as well as being one of the
most environmentally friendly and it
also has the all blacks,
the best national rugby team on the
planet.
Oh,
but let's move on from the rankings
because honestly we could go on forever.
They do seem to make one thing clear
though,
and that is that on paper New Zealand,
it sure does look like one of the best
places in the world to live.
Okay.
By the way.
Here is a surprising fact about alto.
Rob,
as it said in Maori,
which is an official language that the
New Zealand is a really proud of the
Maori culture and it's the integration
of these Polynesian people that the
British pounds when they arrived on
these islands,
it is true no matter where you go,
the Maori culture is present.
Okay.
All right,
so moving on,
on the 23rd of September,
2017 elections took place in this
country.
Okay,
a record election.
The first thing we need to remember is
that New Zealand is a constitutional
monarchy.
That's right,
Elizabeth.
The second is still the queen of this
country,
but it's really just a symbolic
position.
God Save the Queen in New Zealand,
the government is elected by the
parliaments and the term it lasts for
three years.
Further,
when New Zealand is go to vote,
they have to vote twice.
One of the votes goes to a single
candidates from one political party.
This will complete eight parts of the
parliaments.
The other vote goes to an NP who will
represent their districts.
So as we sat on the 23rd of September,
New Zealand's a held an election and it
was a clear for the National Party of
Bill English.
Bill English already was the prime
minister by the way,
since the resignation of Junky in
December of 2016 we also going to talk
about this former prime minister in an
upcoming video.
So again,
please do hit that subscribe button.
So this victory for the national posse,
well it was historic in a way,
and this was for two reasons.
First because this party had never got
so many votes in an election and seconds
because if the new government is
confirmed for the National Party would
have been in power since 2008 for the
longest period in office for a party in
New Zealand for more than 50 years.
And truth be told,
there are plenty of reasons why bill
English one as we have seen,
the country is in great shape.
In fact,
it is going through one of the best
moments in its history.
The economy is growing,
unemployment is higher than the average
and the unemployment is pretty scarce.
Plus they also have healthy public
finances.
Mr. English is eight years.
His finance minister,
unemployment fell.
The budget return to a surplus and New
Zealand enjoyed one of the highest
growth rates in the developed world.
The National Party's intention is to
continue with the politics that they've
carried out since 2008 and that's more
trade balanced budgets and also trying
to keep immigration rates higher than
ever.
This has actually been a very important
aspect of their political campaign.
I mean,
if it's not broken,
don't fix it.
181,000 jobs have been created in the
last two years and the average annual
wage is up $13,000 under national.
Someone working on the minimum wage has
seen their annual income go up $8,000
since 2008 Bill English.
Despite this,
all the campaign hasn't been as
comfortable as some expected.
After all,
even in the most prosperous country,
there are challenges and unresolved
issues.
Mamia and challenges
just into done was elected leader of the
Labour Party policy.
It wasn't exactly going through its best
moments.
In the elections of 2014 the Labour
party barely gone to 25% of the vote,
about half the votes of Junkies National
Party.
However,
shortly after they choose a new leader
who was only 37 years old.
Well,
things that things started to change,
the press,
they call this just sinned.
A mania.
Two things have been the keys of
Jacinta's campaign housing and
immigration.
You see one of the problems in New
Zealand is the price of houses.
Something that has skyrocketed in the
last few years.
The price of housing has increased much
more than in Australia or Canada or the
United States.
New Zealand to tops world house price
increase,
but why is the price of housing growing
quite so much?
Well,
that's for several reasons,
but there are three main causes.
First,
economy and salaries are increasing a
lot in New Zealand.
Second's immigration rates are higher
than ever.
This is one of the countries that
receives the most immigrants every year
relative to their population and it's
more immigrants.
That means the greater demand.
How's it?
Because many millionaires investors,
especially from Asia but also from other
parts of the world.
Once a buy houses here to put their
money in a safe place and also to enjoy
the country.
One example of these people would be
Jack Mar,
the CEO of Alibaba does the National
Party.
They wanted to tackle this issue by
making construction easy and fast.
The Labor Party have just Endura done
came up with two suggestions.
First,
reducing the number of immigrants by
half and second is preventing foreign
investors from buying houses in New
Zealand.
It was this speech on Housing and
immigration that got him the support of
the Party and Poles.
It seemed to indicate that at times it
was a very close race,
but once the election's arrived,
the Kiwis,
well they did not hesitate.
Okay,
let's be clear.
New Zealand,
it's a great country,
but it does have some obstacles to
overcome housing and proving Mallory
integration and technical education are
a few of these things,
but in the grand scheme of things,
they're pretty small problems.
Now we're going to discuss some of these
problems in a future video,
but for now,
New Zealanders,
they can enjoy some of the best living
standards in the wells anyway.
Now it's your turn.
We'd love to know what you think.
Would you like to spend some time in New
Zealand?
What do you think of the country as a
whole?
Well,
leave your comments in the comment
section below and do not forget to
subscribe to our channel for brand new
videos every Monday and Thursday.
Also,
do not forget to check out our friends
of the reconsider media podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this episode
that we're not mine,
and as always,
thank you for watching.